Thank you very much to the team of chefs with
Mexico for having organized
this event so complex and with so much effort
and I really like doing this type of
animation
it is something too long and complicated to
produce so much more new is
perfect I have the sites like this
They were in high school in 2008 and out of curiosity I
simply began to read a little about
html and css and outlining this marvelous
site where basically what I did was
ask my high school classmates for
the CD booklets,
they changed and uploaded it, because you could
buy a  sometimes I could buy here
as it was the same the images inside and they
had to carry music they had
from perry britney spears to
green bay evanescence it's pretty good
all the texts were blue in the links
simply because I didn't know how to change
balls so I did  that I'm very
fond of him at the beginning even if it's like
this or not enough years and I discovered
that I quite like making sites and that I
enjoyed it
among the sites that I had created I
had also created sites about beards
that I liked artists that I would like to
create a sip  about subsidiaries and another about
keating if you have a metal guard
regarding if I can't look for it
I like it a lot like that kind of creating
sites and maybe even to complete
I imagined the musicians how I could start
receiving messages
we have then it's incredible and we have
live finished to  things
bayern and I had to make that decision to
choose what you wanted to know when good
big but the time had also come for you
and sofia that they wanted to know felt
agreements I knew I liked it
so I had the opportunity to apply for
a scholarship to pay for my studies at
My first year of tertiary university I
would not do a short degree and in that scholarship they
asked me specifically in the
application because I wanted this already ready,
which surprised me a lot because
in general I was used to the fact that
when someone gives me a scholarship
I had to justify their
academic merits  and not so much to propose because
we studied interest so it is one of the
things that I really liked the most about
that scholarship application that we had to
show how interesting it was
called as a passion for what
we wanted to study and this was
above where it is
because we could have high school so
I found my 18-year-old application
the other day and it said something quite as
if it were a little letter to pay the
hairs the day I want to organize
people it was returned allows that
many many years and today I continue
working
and this  as quite positive about the future
that comes
among several causes attending the
talk to achieve diversity
and I always kept working at the
beginning and dances because I started
working card in many companies
included in all this time since
I maintained the love and passion that  I
now have a web so I want to show you the
touch of the things that I liked the most
in our last 10 years I was
making sites that are pages
that grow with water
it is a very personal movie not too late to
face I really like the space you
can still design  even without being a
designer
it's a lot of images
necessary when we wanted to do some
gradient in 2002 and 2008 we had
to basically open photoshop generate
an image one pixel wide and
repeat it in x and that way I was
quite annoying because as you
wanted  modify that degree sooner
regenerate the image of the expo
to re-upload everything for it
and it takes a long time so today
we have gradients with guidelines for
the gradient that basically does not
solve this problem of having an
image that is really necessary for
something else  of necessary images that
we uploaded a point that perhaps made
2010 more interesting:
rounded edges did not exist in radio shapes
and to be world edges what we
had to do was use 40
elements, one in each corner to
locate an image that we love or photoshop
with a rounded value of the
upper corner, it got there, it positions it, we go
and then we made the same destination in the
lower right and with all the
corner rules and since if we had
the need to modify the color,
it is simply to return it one day, we
would not have to redo everything from  that we
had already done until and when it finally
came back spokes I was very excited it
was like playing I can make
circles it can be more rounded and I don't
have to open photoshop to do that
and I eventually realized that
I couldn't make circles like spokes
because the  The text did not adapt but
nothing happens because today we have
confirmed and 66 and they emerge that
a very simple comma allows us to make
things other than rectangles and make
comments on shapes where the text
adapts to a shape driving
defense color that's right  something that eliminates having
less change images and messages are an
amount costs the server and that is
something prepared because we pay for the
server and also for the user
because he does not have the need to
download those images it is also something
quite large for our code that
remains a lot  simpler and it may be
better
and it is incredible that we are no longer
forced to work
number 9 everything is at 666 I think that smoking
bigger changes that we have experienced in
recent years I am going to mention only
one of my favorites which are the little
arrow function  we select little arrow
although the correct name width
came to improve the way
we were anonymous functions in which
parenthesis function parenthesis we went to
simply see a name of the
little arrow parameter and open and you know and in
this way our but is much more
organized and also allows us  do
things as interesting as not by a
parenthesis and it is only a parameter or
if only an instruction and if
they want good things that more than 6 to
number 8 law in revolution to them I hope they
have not had to learn slogans
and if to turn on  a fire I hope you
know that they are necessary master
priest love you want to enjoy a
life without flowers the products were a
suffering he programmed his life of us
because what we had to do was
put marx patches all the time and it is
very unfortunate that we were not
learning how to build
hacks because this is going to be a standard
that has failed a lot in recent
years the veteran will arrive dear and
texts that are more
wonderful technology that does not allow this bottle
in a very consistent way in a
very stable way fraud and always  the
question is usually sold to the gray launched
to open use texts and the answer is
we should use weapons because they do not
work an
incredible way is that then they are armed
so that they can also be used
together because one and the other
if it has some aspects on how it is
they use as a whole
and a module was also created for the students,
which is a kind of machine in classroom
13 where the alignment is separated and
and the separation of the elements in a
different module is not next to flexo
but is about to villas is a model
other than it happens it is about that
we are things like shooting
brake content or alain items ferrari what we
are using is the post knows
obvious and this way what is seen but is
that the implementation in browsers is
much faster because what it sounds
during this time it is to generate more guys
to be able to be much faster we
implement very quickly I want to love
mentioned this css is
intelligible and we have a lot of css
today to two incredible women who
allowed us to have either browsers
so much you shine with an
acceptance center  of browsers
is a woman extension if you and fill in I
say that they are people who have been working
for 20 years and who have
really managed to get browsers to implement
gray
shows how it works
what changes
position
xml angry
basically you will never have to type
that or say let's jump because  It was
something extremely complex, I was always
wrong about you, but it was wrong to advertise
water and luckily not from the salt block
anymore because they sold we have a date. I'm not going to deny anyway that thanks to xh
from retirement message from http while I
found out that there was 8 418  which is
basically I'm a teapot the scopes
of the history of that in wikipedia in
with interesting and when it started
working date something quite
interesting happened chest it didn't work anywhere it
was a bad idea knowing that
there was a proposal to implement in
browsers but what
none had just been implemented then
of course
regina george showed up saying stock 30 micron
exhaust for many many years they were at
a javascript conference and there
was always regina george telling us that
we still couldn't
nowadays we already have 95% of
the radiators covered with  support
for french and so we can enjoy it
make an expensive program and berlin
number 6 but this is a tag that
is not so new but I think it
changed a lot the way we
write images he answered it is not a
tag that allows us to work with
images fox  and dlh to have and avoid
unnecessary changes to the user then
we can generate an image for the
desktop and we can stop more than
Paraguay to indicate the browser that fits
one or the other
all this from html
then we can deliver with 25
image format this allows the team of
design can be an image internally
it looks better on desktops and one that
may be more elongated sugar by
mullings to work more on
mobile devices
it is something wonderful it works in this
way inverted pictures with different
image accounts the indicator with average
in what size of  We want them to
run on the screen and all this has a
complete form. First, browsers
that do not understand picture, like maybe in
explorer 11, what they do is load
an image per disk 2, which is in this
case the logo in small point png,
we also  It allows you to use it as
new image formats, such as a
hit format, so the browser
can load it,
it returns, it is a format that allows the
jagua, number of bytes in the image,
health, quite interesting.
new format that was launched this year in
September so they do a little bit and it
still takes a level or lose
chrome wrote a whole out and code on
how you can start implementing this
image format and what are the
next cons to be able to use
we work the european pigeon in 25%
in the browsers today so it
is something that lives if they are not using it
it was seen to happen to launch it the
webber format is quite well reached
found 85% and abif again it is something
that we recently launched  in September so it
has a 25 more and presentation but
if they use it with a picture tag what
they do is generate a
completely native fullback drinkers who
have a bit will read and gesture and
fine who can't go to another pgr or a
happy
number  five components action and i don't
mean the beans it's not really
but the concept of components the
concept of components is the amazing thing
that came out in the last few years name
watson a consequence of this
more plant components allow us
to generate architecture that is much more
stable  much more scalable and
allows us to create elements that are centrally
usable so we can build
completely independent comprehensions of
three others and we reuse all the time
and I also think one of the things I
like most about components is
working much better in conjunction with the
design team  As
tablet developers before, we didn't have
such a large collection. It sold me through the
quote. We're working together all the time
and we generate media.
Number four is animations. I know that
rial and components sounds a bit more
important, but I like more
real animation for food.  my data but
now it is known at zero that I
love the company that they do not give me so much
money
the animations of papers and 8-11 adex
some were simply devoted to
erasing eventually it died and when I
entered I left an empty space in many
of the prints because  It was quite
easy to make web animation, very
low back, I got the software and that's it, and
suddenly we were in a space of
how many years more comfortable, third
animations in the quality level so
little, but moving things forward and
we can make very
interesting animations and of  good quality with ccs
it's a ss job
if you want to look for one of 5 see some
interesting account about animation but
I recommend Christian and assimilation it is
perhaps useful like this click but
they are also very nice
mine in which it is done on
purely cdc issues and  html
and we fill in the same thing we fill in is a
person who makes comics and
after a lot of videos on
youtube
about what it's like to work and search how to see
in google one of the largest
form four out of five
I don't know if an ex suffered from not having to
validating email addresses but
basically using
regular expressions those work expressions is
one of the most wonderful and
horrible things that any programming language has
all the time we are
buying books doing it all over the
internet trying to finally
understand and remember what
regular expressions sound like and all  time we
forgot the next day how
they work
that they start creating fake books
with jokes in the middle like
regular expressions that go wrong
combining bars and dots this charge
happens or this other changing things
basically the description of our
job
because the way we
We make regular expressions quite a lot as
sensors when we had to do things
as basic as validating an address
in it. Nowadays we have
native variations that are free like the
email address, those of us don't have to
write that expression to fly the to
the  browser but things as you remember
before we had to write a
javascript to validate so a certain field
was completed it is no longer necessary
today we tried how to use
a box attribute and that happens
we also pass them on forms
interesting things like the timeline the inbox
that we  It allows the keyboard of the
mobile device according to the trade to
make it more comfortable to write a number and
also something incredible that cost a
lot that is applied in browsers that
is the iPod the iPad that is where to click
completely negative in the browser and I do
n't know about you but  When I had to
be a baby kart in the browser I
ended up
wen and very young I was going and we wrote
we wrote javascript and rolling that
please work it is no longer necessary
we have a basic horse riding that we can
use simply writing and
portal you asked
and I am not going to explain  a lot in mexico which
is because i think we're here we don't
know if we know the importance it
had in web development
looking beyond versace's perspective is very interesting
and learning what
was the envy behind recreating an
audi how it goes through the  years
so we can't energy everything so they
are interested
in number 10 because there is nothing I
love more than words of
development especially with a person
who loved the fronton they are amazing
thank you personally develop
weighed with the concept of feedback
taiba that was  a bunch of software that
can be used in firefox and
the years went by and today we have in
all browsers even inhabitants
but the development tools that
are quite good and that help us
on a day-to-day basis to make many
sites today in  day we can work here
also these six and you have that
directly to the browser with a
will design in the design area we can
verify the accessibility we can
verify a progressive works well
they have a failure directly in the browser
without having to spend a month on a phone
and how to use the
browser tools to learn how to use
memory
and then also tools that
are exclusive to the framework of half
of riad
because after having thrown the browser
everything that includes
development tools is incredible and how they have
become our best friend
this kitty  of singing
oh
and we are in an incredible
good also because it rewards when we
enter a site we do not see all those
wonderful things on the face not
necessarily
if I see the bagged world of
user experience there is very good
so what happens in between
when we enter a website we have
accept signs we will conquer
signs please no
block sheets but your criteria must have
complications allowed and when we
finish closing all those next
dans we no longer remember that
we wanted to leave the experience of
browsing sites not today  It's the equivalent
of the experience of everything I'm
saying about being able to improve something that
is the medium.
We had things always happen. This is an
incredible sentence, very funny,
very funny context, I think it's a
house of expression from Argentina, but
it's a company that  I liked that being
felt because it describes this situation
of hunger we had a lot of
young people who passed the web and yet
something fashion let's start to see what
this time they failed what things I like
European to start with because
notifications one day a person
got up and  He said it would be a good idea to have
direct notifications from the browser
that notify you when you have something new,
of course, a good idea, so they
began to create this kind of posters,
as they were asked for a little sign that
would allow sites that give you
notifications
and any site that ends up using even
medicine sites that modify the
buttons basically translates to nothing like
the site would like to send
notifications and the button is allow or
not I don't want to live
what happened but years went by and
basically we started and
browsers like a falcon began to
jump on the site  how to actually enter
feature within the browser like
this blocker of course typical jones
so if you are using a firewall
more suffered the expires in a post it
operations because most of the
points at something they were not interested in
and it is something quite sad because first
we created the technology and it created the
technology for the technology
ok we were wrong because having these
beautiful things the first thing we see
and probably more or less the only thing we
see we just start navigating the
confines is something that was almost always
the last to go  It returned as it
is predominantly in Barinas and cleaning
that Europe has had the sidewalk for more or
less two years, that it is a law that in
reality what it does is talk about
web privacy and I know that many times
one thinks good or worse I have nothing
to hide  and the reality that we have
about it is more than not having anything to tell
is that there are certain things in one's life
that are private,
for example,
and without an investigation that
menstruation tracking applications
are you have seen before they shared the
information of  our menstruation with
third parties then suddenly we
find ourselves in the most beautiful situation
my mom does not know what date it was for me but
on facebook
it is because we are sharing
information that is private and for one
with companies that are ever
abandoned
for knowing that information about us
new ones we said why do I want to give you this
information is what happened because
we are turning these things
into privacy
and that the answer in general is
good the teacher signed up for free but
sometimes I feel that this justification is
a vague justification for not getting it right
that we can only think better and that
maybe we are making a mistake
if encrypted passwords we
are always messages stop
sign messages whatsapp messages why not
encrypt our menstrual periods
because they cannot be if it can be
done but far is creating a
trachea of ​​periods  an application for
the mobile that is completely enchanted
and that's how things should be because the
company should know my dates because it
's my problem so those things
can be done well your mayor
decided accessibility a long time ago
well an
accessibility company from the United States  and they are
investing they are with a million pages
to see how they were
regarding the double message that is the
accessibility guide and 97.8 percent of
that page passed the million pages
and developing as one were under
this pretext so that an image is
easy  of the schedules and lack of
Christian of the air
is not something that someone should come to
teach
nobody should come here to teach or
compose an alternative text of
language we should not know how to do
that and in fact our see so
why don't we do it
was with  shame computers with
clients for mine picos this is something
beautiful that happened in argentina a few
years ago and what he sang to me was a
justification they said it was a mistake I
would love for bucks they were
errors but it's not just what there is
microsoft confirms  that is new cream
this is something that the
typical monopoly that we had of
internet explorer in the 90s and the end
of doping and we know that not only did it not
go well to have 90% of
users use a single browser is to
know that up to date  today everything and
we already have agreements that work
badly or because they were put together just
to work and to wait for
this movement to kill a
character
and how we started to let him soon
have diversity
but I'm happy giving you your photogenic and
darken your place  receive the courses your
literal site not this occasion of temptation
is this but your fade said I want to be
my black belt and hired people
to make your site in black and this
site that in a black company weighs 800
mb that's why a black htm  empty with
a line of 400 that passed I don't know how many
above stop playing with the estuary to do
this that hey what is happening to us
we had also
well what happened to us also
if we had so much technological development
so many good things happening to us in the
world  You want a lot of web and because we
are forgetting the user they are
lying losing on sideburn we
are just tired it is something
quite complex because if I sold
we look maybe a development labor authority
in general end up
living some where happy record that
enough accessibility is mandated be
someone  put a value attribute
in an image tag it is not
sending our blind gestures that they will
see it is not a lack of knowledge or a
lack of time
that is due to the amount of things
we have today if we have some things
to impress we have to
worry about how to make a
rounded tournament at the same time we are
trying to do everything and we are
only a few people so we
end up making indian graves
and we end up seeing each other we end up
waiting a lot more for the situation with
bidder syndrome where we think
everyone  knows everything but I don't have
time for anything
there are so many things to learn and there is so
little time and desire there is a life more
hours of work
I want to say to everyone more that they like
what is a good thing there will be moments they
felt we are going to push repel which
because  for more in my case I love the
front it says a little bit of baker that
task only good don't let them overcome you
don't feel bad appearance it's perfect
that you specialize in something you have to
learn a little from the other you don't
have to be experts  In all, it is
really a beautiful number and I think
we can do incredible things as
shown and I think that precisely in this
year 2020
the importance of taking that
step to connect with the web is something of importance, we have to
take care of it a little more and
we also have  We have to take care of the user and
when they made us work
we inspected internal elements
to solve it but to say a world of access
to the ground as it needs for it to
work for you it needs that the site that
uses a screen reader
because then a blind person
in another way of navigating  another way to
use web web
and also take care of each other
because if we could not each other
how are we going to do nice things I
have to say that we
are also getting closer such as
vacations to connect your colleagues
continue with my name he is tired he asks
why they need that  they can't
help to really be able to be all
right and to be able to continue in wonderful things
videos
so don't increase thanks to the
complex in my flesh and I hope
we have an excellent day today